um you know for me it's you know it's an
incredibly exciting movement I mean
there's always been great designers
creating clothing you know a tad more
accessible price point for me I have
questions of manufacturing and I bring
in an eye I question an ethical issue I
believe in quality and luxury so in that
instinct you can't achieve high quality
and luxury inn in a lower price point
you can create a look and an idea and
something that is temporary and has an
end and I think it's incredible I mean
it's a wonderful thing for for design
for design at lower price points and not
I don't like the word mass because I
think it's too general so I don't really
use that or this word mass teej in
fashion is a big word but you know the I
it the idea of design for less is an
incredible idea will be really will will
change fashion
you